Speaker 1: All right, let's speak next
to let's just go across the pond to
Connor from Dublin. Connor, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi. Hi, David. I have one question,
please question only. This is a secret
Trump supporters. So obviously so we
we know lots of Irish immigrants who live
in Pennsylvania. And the Irish communities
are very liberal, a very Democratic one that
they secretly voted for Trump. Really. And
it's quite strange. Their idea is, is that
they just they moved to America with nothing
and they have and they've worked and they
have a lot of money now and they just want
to hold onto the money. They don't care about
policy. They don't care about any issues. They
just want to keep their money. Yeah, so and
so how do we how do we reach these people?
Speaker 1: I mean, I don't know that we reached
them in any particularly different way than we
reach anybody. But what you're pointing to is is
very important. And we took a call from a Chinese
Canadian caller a couple of weeks ago who
pointed out a lot of the a lot of Chinese
immigrants who would be sort of like
my parents age, I guess you would say,
are far more conservative than many would assume.
And this this gets back to Republicans love to say
that the strategy of Democrats on immigration
is let as many people in naturalize as many
people as possible so that then they'll vote
for you in future elections. I've I've pointed
out that that doesn't make sense because it's
a really slow process. And if the U.S. only
naturalize is eight hundred thousand people a
year and only some of them vote and only some
of them vote for Democrats, it's like a really
dumb thing to do. But what's missing from it
is there are way more immigrants than people think
who actually vote for Republicans. There's a whole
bunch of Russian immigrants frequently vote for
Republicans. Venezuelan and Cuban immigrants often
vote for Republicans, Chinese immigrants
of a certain age, as you're pointing out,
Irish. So, yeah, it's it's not surprising to me.
Speaker 2: Great. Well, thank you very much.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Great, great topic,
an important topic that I'm glad to see come
up frequently. Let's go next while we have
a packed waiting room. It's shocking what
is going on right now. I don't even know where
to go. Let's try Mike from New York next. Mike,
you're on the air. Mike from New York, you're
on the air, my friend. Is it our first drop,
Mike, you've got to unmuted yourself or I won't be
able to hear you. That's too bad, that's too bad.